hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast deep phenotyping of
t-regs in health and disease lessons
from bone marrow failure syndromes
presented by
dr chakram kordasi a senior lecturer in
cancer
immunopathology at king's college london
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is brought
to you by
lab roots and sponsored by beckmann
coulter
for more information on our sponsor
please visit them at www.beckman.com
now let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask question box and
click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report a problem by clicking the ask
box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuous
education credits please click on the
continuing education
credits tab located at the top of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
without further ado i'd like to
introduce our presenter today
dr shahram kardashi for a complete
biography
of our speaker please visit our
biography tab at the top of the screen
dr gaddafi you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
okay thank you very much good morning
afternoon or good night
depends where you are in the world and
thank you very much for inviting me uh
basically today i'm going to talk about
deep phenotyping of t-rex and this is an
example
and i'm trying to use our work in past
few years how we
use new approaches in identifying
cell types and a better definition of
some of the cells that you already know
we use that to identify subgroups of
patients use them as a biomarker for
response to therapy
and actually how some aspects of these
uh lead to new therapy
in patients so i am a hematologist by
training and
my background very much is on bone
marrow failure syndrome which i
explained a bit more
and i apologize if there are uh
hematologists uh
within the audience that some parts
related to definition of bone marrow
failure may be
a bit boring for you but this is the
uh basically the
sponsorship of this talk
so when we talk about
big data revolution i very much like to
go back to this very
interesting paper published in nature
immunology
a few years ago that highlights the
importance of teaching big data analysis
to young immunologists and this
aspect of big data really changed the
way we
approach identifying biomarkers
finding how to classify patients
diseases and approach treatment on these
patients
so we used to think when it was
finding a biomarker we used to come up
with a hypothesis
design an experiment do observation and
finding a biomarker that we thought okay
that is what
is important and that's uh what that's
the one basically that gives us
information about a patient or a group
of patients
but big data really changed the way we
look at the designing experiments
what we use to say about
data mining or
kind of phishing exercise was
a bad word in science maybe it's not
that bad
anymore because thanks to cheaper
omics data we could
do what we call data-driven
systems immunology for instance in the
field of immunology that i am working on
and design of experiments sometimes come
from this omix data and
this omix data of course they are not
just
one type of data we are talking about
several different types of data
that they can integrate they can combine
and give you a far more comprehensive
data and
for instance microbiome genomic
epigenome
transcriptomic and cytome
which is maybe you
is is kind of less known with this name
but
thanks to a multi-dimensional cytometry
using
site-off using uh more advanced flow
cytometry
data that we get the cyto also integrate
to this data
other omics data and
this big data can be used for patient
stratification and identifying new
cell types etc and i would like
to show you as an example
how cyto can be used
and we have used it uh in combination
with other
methods or mixed methods to identify
sometimes new subtypes of t-rex
and how it was relevant in predicting
response to therapy and led to
identifying new targets for therapy
but before i go there i would like to
just explain what is bone marrow failure
syndromes
uh again apologize uh for uh any
hematologist that it's in the
audience but bone marrow failure
syndrome as you can
tell from the name is when the bone
marrow fades
so bone marrow is the main source of all
blood cells that we have and if it fails
basically you don't have enough
blood cells you have anemia you may have
a low number of white blood cells etc
etc
and as you can see on the right side if
you look at a healthy bone marrow
in somebody around 50 years old you can
see a 50 50
cellularity in the bone marrow and then
the bone marrow failure happens
it's a very complex condition you have
several different
subtypes of bone marrow failure
from autoimmune types of bone marrow
failure
we call it aplastic anemia which
you have immune response against uh
bone marrow cells and you have basically
an empty bone marrow so there is
no cell to produce blood components
or in the other end you have malignant
transformation that you do
have cells in the bone marrow but they
and you have actually too many of them
and if you compare the mds with the
healthy bone marrow
what we call myelodysplastic syndrome
which is a
kind of myeloid malignancy these cells
accumulate in the bone marrow and they
cannot differentiate
so these malignant cells basically take
over the bone marrow
all of them lead to bone marrow failure
the this bone marrow failure of course
if you put aside those that are they
have genetic background
these autoimmune to malignant
diseases like mds and aml you have
some sort of immune dysregulation and we
always say these patients they have
immune dysregulation
the question is what is immune
dysregulation is it the same as
autoimmunity
and if you do a bit of search and
perhaps go to
uh wikipedia you see that immune
dysregulation
uh defined as a pseudoscientific term
which actually i disagree with that what
we mean by immune dysregulation
is um we have
perhaps in two end of ends of this
spectrum you have auto inflammation it's
very much
defined by a myeloid drug inflammation
in body
that neutrophil macrophages etc they
induce a very uh inflammatory
environment nlrp3 pathways
active oil one beta is involved
and in the other end you have a
self-antigen
recognition t cell and b cells are
involved
and you have autoimmunity cell and a
cellular response
specifically against specific type of
cells
and in between you have mixed pattern
diseases and
this is something that we see mainly in
bone marrow failure
and if i uh want to
compare this mds or
myelodysplastic syndrome which is a
malignant type of bone marrow failure
sit
in the middle of these two you have
elements of water inflammation and you
have elements of
autoimmune disease and depends on what
other subtypes
aplastic anemia is more or less an
autoimmune type
and you have a condition called sweet
syndrome that
is very much autoinflammatory today we
are going to focus
mainly on aplastic anemia and how this
disease is
what evidence we have that this disease
is autoimmune
it's published several papers years ago
uh showed the expansion of oligocolonol
cd8
that potentially they recognize
antigens and they are antigen specific
and they induce autoimmunity and their
response to immunosuppression and when
you give immunosuppression they
disappear
it's also shown that uh other cells like
uh fox p3 are
uh reduced and th17
uh cells are increased in this patient
so cd4 are also involved
and we have shown on others as well
that t-rex are significantly reduced in
aplastic angle so you don't have enough
t-rex
and the less t-rex you have the more
severe disease you have
and the ratio of t-rex to t helpers are
also different
and you can based on number of t-rex
predict response to therapy excellent
so you think okay we have a biomarker
that you can predict response to therapy
there is a problem and the problem is
how you define t-rex t-rex
are perhaps the most controversial cells
one of them at least in immunology in
terms of how you define and how you
define the
subpopulations
cd425 high is something considered
majority of them are t-rex not all of
them
in human is uh fox b3 which considered
one of the markers for t-rex is not very
specific
you can see inactivated t-cells as well
and of course there are definitions some
population of t-rex
uh which they are known as
sakoguchi sub-population fraction one
two and three
uh which they have different uh function
and different markers based on
expression of cd45 ra and fox v3
and there are a suggestion that in in
each
condition in tumor tissue and peripheral
blood you may have
a different composition of these t-rex
but i want to highlight a problem
so if you want to define t-rex in
aplastic enemy and in a healthy donor
on right side you have healthy donor in
middle you have non-responder means that
the aplastic anemia patient who
not he will not respond
to immoral suppression and on the left
those patients who will respond to
immunosuppression if you want to gate
cd4 t
cells it's quite as straightforward and
i asked three experts that are
internationally known in the field of
t-rex
to get these t-rex for me and i wanted
to see
how similar their gating gatings are
more or less the same when you ask them
to get
cd3 and cd4 but when it comes to
definition
of cd25 high
really you can see that the definition
by these three experts
is not uh similar you have
a a considerable difference none of them
are
wrong and what i'm trying to say is not
that
they are wrong or right they use their
own criteria and as long as
within their lab and within the
experiment they are doing they use the
same
criteria is fine but the problem is how
you're gonna compare these when you have
a multi-center study or when you want to
compare the results between two labs and
two different
uh research groups same with the
fox b3 expression again you can see the
definition is not very
consistent between the three people that
i asked them to do this skating
and that makes a range that it's quite
different
between these patients and healthy donor
and makes it a bit difficult to compare
and if you go to the
some population one two three
it makes it even more difficult because
uh
everybody could argue why you put the
gate here and not there
so we decided to start using uh
cytomorph cyto for mass cytometry
whatever you call it
but nowadays mainly uh known as siteof
cytometry of time of flight that
basically you use metal tag
antibodies and you can go up to
30 or 35 or 40 different markers depends
on the machine and
panel you are using at single cell level
and use basically mass spec
to identify those metals and see
what is the element uh what expression
you have at single cell level
that part you can of course use flow
cytometry data
with the latest generation of flow
cytometries
you can do more or less the same number
of markers
but the problem is the data when it
comes out
is massive is
if you want to do the 2d plot as you
usually do in philosophy
it's very difficult to compare and even
make sense of it
and this is a paper in science 2011 one
of the first paper published about sites
of
it's it's almost impossible and even if
you compare these
uh 2d plots again
how they correlate with each other is
very difficult
and this is a slide i borrowed from
my colleague and collaborator uh dr
jonathan irish
at vanderbilt university and uh he has
kindly provided me with this
is basically
you have a massive amount of data this
amount of data
you can then use
dimension reduction and then engineering
cell function based on that dimension
reduction and
identify cell types or redefine cell
type or better defined cell types
based on these uh group of cell islands
you identify
so it's an approach you need to do and
this is
the paper published by jonathan's group
that
they have suggested this pipeline which
we acquired and we used as well
that you can combine dimension reduction
uh do the
clustering and do the uh expression
based on marker enrichment modeling that
allow you to define when you identify a
cell population
what do they express and how much of it
they express or they don't
and this man is quite important and
this is again published by jonathan's
team in
2017 that
with the same median you may have a
different
enrichment and you can use that to
better define
your population of cells and if a cell
type
is positive or negative for something
how positive
or negative it is and uh this is
basically
i think fundamentally change the way we
look at positivity or negativity or
level of expression of different
markers on each cell type in immunology
go to our data we have used mass
cytometry to
do exactly the same look at regulatory t
cells and we identified regulatory t
says
on panel a you can see that cd25
high fox b3 positive one to seven
low cells are a separate island within
cd4
although cd4 they are not very well
class clustered and differentiated but
we wanted to see t-rex it was enough to
identify t-rex on that time
of course the panel was as extensive uh
as what we do now on that time but
uh what we've noticed is and
those t-rex if you look at the density
of t-rex you can see that
actually there are two separate
population quite distinct
uh populations in healthy donor there
are much we call them tiering a
and b in majority of in healthy donor
majority of them are t rate b
whereas in patients who receive
immunosuppression aplastic anemia
you have a difference in non-responder
those patients he will not respond you
have
t reg a which will go more
into explaining what are those and then
in those responders they are closer to
healthy donor in terms of percentage of
t reg a
and b and that
can predict response to therapy and as
you can see in
figure e there is a significant
difference between the
composition of t-rex and responder
non-responder patients
and this true population of t-rex
are defined by a memory and naive
phenotype but that is not just
enough to define them because they have
other markers like cd95 or ccr4 which
define them
more details and this cd95 is
one to remember uh which one of the
very clear difference between tyric a
and b
t-reg b which is a composition of
majority of t-rex in a healthy donor or
patient who respond
they are cd95 positive but as t-rex a
almost they don't have
95 expression
of course the review i want to see how
these
two population correlate with a
population that conventionally be
defined within t-rex t-rex one two three
and interestingly uh one t-rex
one anterior two are
more or less the same as theory a and b
uh in our approach
population three which is very much
controversial in
in immunology and we think is a mixture
of different types of t-rex
you can see they are uh overlaying
mainly with t-rex b
and the some part of population three
they cluster outside of the tearing area
and therefore they are most likely they
are not t-rex
so you can define true population of
t-rex that covers these three
populations
and these three populations more or less
become
true more clear
automated and less buyers defined
population and this is a summary of the
paper we published
a few years ago that this composition of
t-reg is a predictor for response
and that's ongoing to be validated as a
prediction
uh for response to immunosuppression
therapy in patients with aplastic anemia
and that's an ongoing study
but these t-rex uh you may ask okay so
if you have tear a and b that said you
don't have any subpopulation this is
another study a collaboration with
dr ben afzali at nih we did that
basically within t rate b we have
noticed that there is a
uh subpopulation of theoretic b
that they express cd161
which was a bit uh surprising for us
because
cd161 more or less considered an nk
marker
at least on that time and
or for tea helpers and therefore we
didn't expect to have
cd161 t-rex
using the same approach as you can see
the class that differently
and they do have a different
uh expression of markers
compared to t-reg a and b as well so
cd 161
more or less they have a more activated
phenotype and different from the other
true subpopulation although
they are part of t rate b but they are
distinct as well
and if you go deeper do single cell
rna-seq they cluster separately
and the expression of
rna is different as well
even more interestingly if you look at
the cytokinin profile of these t-rex
they have a mixture of pro-inflammatory
and
suppressive cytokine profile
like il-10 and oil-17
both at protein level as well as at rna
level
nevertheless they are very much
suppressive and
the suppression function
is more or less the same as other t-rex
so you have a t-rex
that uh produce uh
pro-inflammatory cytokine but it's very
much
immunosuppressive and
if again if you analyze the pathway that
control the
raw seed which is important for the
expression of cd161 and this
is a gene called back to which when you
don't have back to
the cd161 expression exists
and in patients with
a very rare disease called breeder
which is back to related
immunodeficiency and autoimmunity
that they have a combination of repeated
infection and signs of autoimmunity
these t-rex are increased so because
basically you don't have bacteria
and the t-rex expressed more ct-161
and it is important because also in
myeloid drug inflammation when you have
the inflammation
at a progenitor level in the bone marrow
presence of bacteria and inflammation
and tlr4
activation lead to down regulation of
bacteria
and differentiation towards more of the
macrophage
and more of the myeloid drug
inflammation
so the reason i showed this part is
yes we identified t-rex population that
are better defined and these two
population are quite distinct and very
clear but they are not
the only sub-population within them you
can identify stock population with a
specific function
which can lead to identification
of cells with a specific function
related to specific diseases
and this approach really helps and this
is reproducible
less biased than you can identify them
but let's go back to our first
question and our uh own
disease the bone marrow failure syndrome
and we said okay these t-rex are
different
in non-responder and they don't have
t-rex b
and if you don't have t-right b the
t-reg b is
uh if you don't have t-right b the
disease is more severe and
they don't respond to immune suppression
therapy very well
why and remember i talk about cd95
and cd95 is fast so
the immediate question was is it because
we have a lot of fast ligand
and this ligand attached to this fast or
cd95
and induced apoptosis of t-rex
so first we sorted some t-rex from a
plastic anemia
and indeed the pathway which were
we did rna sequencing and the pathway
which are upregulated in these
cells are very much fast related
and they express homing receptor and the
fast is high
this paper just published a couple of
weeks ago and now is
uh available uh and you can read a
lot so
then we put these t-rex in culture with
fast ligands
and we wanted to see uh
uh basically if we add
a fast ligand can we induce apoptosis
on these cells or not and indeed if you
add fast ligand
you can see that you increase uh the
apoptosis and this uh confirmed the
hypothesis that we had
so but
if they are t reg b going to apoptosis
within the culture in this culture and
the number reduced why the t-rex a
cannot expand
so you don't have one subtype one the
other subtype is not expanded
is it because they don't have enough uh
il2
we tested this by looking at
phosphorylation our stat 5 which is
a method to identify
the for the response to il-2
and if you have low-dose oil too you can
see that
t-reg a they don't phosphorylate the sat
form
as good as t rate b so in other words
they don't respond very well to
low those are two but if you give them
some
more time with more oil too uh
they do uh phosphorylate
so it seems like having more il2
uh is enough to phosphorylate
uh stat five and we ask if we give
enough oil to
can we expand these cells
and yes if you give oil should they
expand very well
and in patients even more than healthy
donor
expansion of this t-rex so these t-rex
are really
primed to expand but they don't have
enough oil too
and then they expand the uh the
ventilated
t-rex tsdr orteric-specific methylating
region
and the ventilated region that
suggest that these t-rex are more stable
and if you have oil too also
by adding oil to you prevent the
apoptosis so they become resistant to
fast ligand as well so not only expand
t-rex but they make them
fast elegant resistant
why that happen we screen these t-rex
for different protein and the protein
that
actually uh phosphorus and upregulate
following giving oil to is bcl2 and bcl
to prevent apoptosis
so this is the mechanism lead to a
resistant to apoptosis
are they stable if you look at this
panel a you can see that
if you put these t-rex in a
polarizing environment
the t-rex before expansion they can
polarize to th17
express will secrete a lot of oil-17 but
if you
expand them in the presence of very high
dose of oil too
uh more or less they are resistant to
they're not plastic anymore they don't
have plasticity to change to
all 17 secreting cells
and they remain functional both of them
and
as you can see whether it's patient or
healthy donor
uh they very well functional and
suppress the proliferation
and the question is can we use this as a
therapy considering the t-rex cell
are very important for cell therapy and
autoimmunity
can use it as a therapy for a plastic
enemy for those patients
who will not respond who will not
respond to immunosuppression
uh we use a mass model using uh gvhd
and see whether this t-rex first or for
how long they
remain in the mouse and
more or less they remain around six
weeks or longer
you can detect them again this is the
paper uh published
just a couple of weeks ago in blood and
it's
now available and if you follow these
uh t-rex so basically to see
where they go and how they control the
bone marrow failure you can see you can
follow them
and do daily monitoring and
check the weight loss and here you can
see that
when you inject t-rex you prevent weight
loss
and the survival of those mice
are much better than without t-rex so
they prevent gvhd and prevent the bone
marrow failure as well
if you remember the first slide i've
shown you uh
that a plastic enemy is more or less an
empty bone marrow you can see here
exactly the same
when you don't have to your exam by
giving t-rex you prevent
that bone marrow failure
nevertheless when you inject
before you inject you can do sight off
and by doing sight off you can see the
expression is uh uh
basically more or less the same
between aaa and healthy donors and this
is the
the analysis done by cytobank that
basically we do
dimension reduction and then we identify
population and then we compare
these populations
and then before and after six weeks we
took the t-rex
out and see whether the expression still
remains the same
in healthy donor interestingly much not
much difference after
injection and after six weeks but in a
healthy dorm
in a plastic anemia the expression
start changing and one of the main
changes is
against cd95 seems like these t-rex they
have a memory of inflammation
and when they go to inflammatory
environments they
may actually still um
downregulates cd95 but they remain
functional
and they prevent as good as healthy
donor t-rex gbht in this patient they
are slightly more clonal of course in
patients
the question was is impatient for
instance in
mds that we have inflammation do we have
the same
uh feature and for this we used um
protein and mrna single cell rna
sequencing
to compare this uh between peripheral
blood and bone marrow
and as you can see in peripheral blood
more or less the
t-rex are the same profile whereas in
bone marrow you have two different
profiles in patients which are
transformed to malignancy versus those
that are
still in the inflammatory phase or
earlier stage of the disease
and what makes a difference in lower
risk disease which is
kind of more uh inflammatory
is that they have low expression
of cd95 and very much similar to what
you've seen in that mouse model so
seems like these t-rex also can be used
as an
indication of presence of inflammation
in these patients
and this inflammation is nothing to do
with t-cell receptor
perhaps and more or less they are
non-specific inflammation
so to summarize this t-rex a
and b are a kind of
umbrella of defining t-rex and within
that you can identify
several different sub-population and
in our case we found two population
which are important for
treatment and a prediction of response
to therapy or
using as a biomarker for inflammation
but for other diseases other
subpopulation might be important
and what it highlights is
really is is again a slide that's kindly
provided by
jonathan and it's
basically uh
shows that the story of when we started
uh years ago with light microscopy
became a long way to define a
high-dimensional the relatively good
speed
subpopulation that can have clinical
implications
to summarize specifically for this
study that in past few years we are
doing
i can say that t-rex are an important
player in overall immune dysregulation
in bone marrow failure
and a novel approach like
multi-dimensional
cytometry give us opportunity to
identify
novel cell populations and redefine the
classic
subtypes of cells like
t-rex and these t-rex that we identified
can be used as an immunometer if you
like
for inflammation for response to therapy
and show
where we are with the autoimmunity or
inflammation
and can be used of course for cell
therapy
i would like to thank the team
that most of the work been done by them
thomas benedetta costantini
uh done a lot of this work uh
shock ping lim uh also done
uh majority of uh cell culture and work
saeed mian and others that have been
involved on this project
also sponsors and
basically funding bodies
i would like to thank cancer research uk
a and mds foundation bloodwise
uk that sponsored and
support our work
and collaborators around the world that
we are working with uh particularly i
would like to
thank jonathan irish from vanderbilt
university
uh nied young ben afzali and
claudia kemper from nih and others that
are cannot go through
all the names and i finished with this
i remember when we published in 2016 uh
the paper uh defining these two
population there was an editorial
and the title of editorial about the
paper was how deep can you go into t-rex
and my answer is well we need to go all
the way
and we need to learn a lot about them
until your own early days so thank you
for listening
and i'm very happy to take
questions
thank you dr kudasti for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just
simply click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's take a look at our incoming
questions
from our audience members dr kardashi
why is it important to better understand
t-reg's
and their sub-populations
well t-rex are for a very long time
are considered a
main player in autoimmunity in cancer in
other diseases but at the same time
they've never been and still there is
not a consensus in terms of how we
define these cells
and if we don't define it universally
and
the way that it's unbiased if you like
or less biased
it makes it difficult to compare studies
to do biggest studies multi-center
studies
and therefore i think it's very
important to identify this
sub-population to better understand
first the immunology of t-rex and second
to use them
for a more um
or better informed studies and better
uh kind of uh
less biased study
thank you and thank you for that and
thank you to our audience members
for these great questions our next
question
dr quiroski how sis how does systems
immunology affect today the day-to-day
clinical practice
okay good question this is uh basically
i think uh i i hope i convince you that
by this study that in past few years
we've been doing
we identified biomarker for a disease
that
how patients when they come to clinic
and come to your clinic
and you want to treat them is likely to
respond to treatment or not and you need
to find
alternative treatments and second is
basically what it helps is that
you can identify new treatments novel
treatments
and that is equally important so
this was an example and i wanted to just
show that
cytometry or cyto which is a part of the
more systems immunology
how affect our clinical practice in
longer term
integrating this data with other
marketplaces here we did
rna-seq and protein level
we identified these cells but
combining with clinical data with other
omics data you may even go further and
identify new targets for therapy
for so many other diseases
thank you for that we have one more
question how important
is system systems immunology for next
generation of scientists
and junior doctors okay
yes immunology uh i think the first
slide is is um tomorrow to
more or less what we discussed is
system dominology that
the idea of one type of cells
one subset of cells one uh biomarker
uh perhaps is not enough having a
more comprehensive and then of course
identify for instance here in this case
we are that one
cell that are important but you cannot
see these cells in isolation you need to
look at
other cells you can look at have a
better understanding of
all the immune system as a whole how it
works for instance in a plastic anemia
you need to look at cd8 look at t-rays
and you can look at all of them
to have a better understanding and
therefore if you design a treatment
rather than focusing on one type of
cells
you do for instance in aa we give atg
with effect
the cells fine but can we combine it
with a
therapy that expand periods at the same
time so you look at different subtypes
different cell types different therapies
therefore it's important for future
generation of scientists to
have a more comprehensive look
if you like into immunology and not
just everybody has a niche everybody has
a
specific interest but looking at
everything
i think is important and learning new
techniques
learning single cell techniques learning
unbiased data analysis which can be
these days are different platforms like
cytobank you can use
to analyze your data the less bias
mode i think are important
thank you and thank you for this great
presentation today
dr kardasi do you have any final
comments for our audience members before
we leave today
okay thank you very much for listening
and i hope it was helpful
and uh what i just want to say is
we are in a new era of uh big data
uh that has changed us and changed
fundamentally the way we do science
and it's important for next generation
to keep
themselves up to date with these
techniques and
uh become more uh
computer savvy if you like
the tool everybody needs
absolutely and thank you again for your
important research sir
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and further interesting questions
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted on
the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via contact information you provided at
the time of your registration
i'd also like to thank labruts for their
time
um and for sponsoring and for beckmann
coulter for sponsoring
and underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
take care be safe bye bye